[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're going to talk about
stuff that you've told us that you're
really into and we're probably gonna rip
it to shreds
no we're just gonna process it and
assess it we're gonna help we're going
to assess it if you need to abandon this
thing we'll let you know that if we have
some advice that we think that you need
to hear as you approach liking this
thing we're just gonna give some
perspective and let me tell you we know
well I'll tell you what yeah we know
that we've got a patient this is this
bearded man right here next to me I've
certainly been into a lot of different
stuff if you haven't listened to our
Rhett Slayers episode from way back if
you want to if you want to pick apart
what rets into or has been into in
fleeting fashion over the many years
that I've known him I don't like that's
a good thank you with that character to
listen to layers but we're both into
things and so we're qualified to to
assess if other people's stuff that
they're into is worth it I'll tell you
there's some I always said some strange
addictions but it's borderline strange
addiction stuff that's happening here
and just some odd unexpected things that
I think it's important that we talk
about so well that might be over selling
it I think we got to oversell it I mean
I think if this if if this you know my
teas in episode you immediately rip it
to shreds go with me you're too
sensational because I would say if you
went your entire life without hearing
the things that we're about to say you'd
probably be okay you don't know what
we're about to say I mean I'm saying
that's you my best guess at this listen
I'm gonna say some stuff I think you're
gonna have a good time change your life
I think I'm gonna have a good time I
think that you're gonna hopefully you're
gonna laugh hopefully you're gonna feel
like this was a good use of your time
that you were entertained and if you
were one of the individuals that we will
be addressing maybe this could be
life-changing but for the average person
listening who didn't submit one of these
things you know you can kind of take it
or leave it
what
it's not even do it don't you gotta
understand what I'm doing I'm doing a
reverse psychology you're doing what
you've learned in 20 years of marriage
right
lower the bar yes because anything
really there man you know what I'm
really glad I listened and Rhett told me
that I wouldn't be then the next time
they'll be like maybe it's always worth
listening this episode's gonna suck but
if you love us you'll stick with us I'll
tell you something I'm into right off
the bat because something happened to me
and it was strange I'm I'm getting
really into physical therapy because
I've been into physical fitness but it
might seem interesting in our age
usually physical therapy something you
get into because you were prescribed it
for a specific condition and I was I
currently have a prescription for
physical therapy sitting in my car
unused yeah that's that's called a
you're a card-carrying middle-aged man
is basically what that means I'm into
physical fitness which at my age means
I'm into physical therapy I think that
you when you're thinking if you go into
a gym and they give you a contract just
go ahead and say okay I'm gonna add in
the cost of physical therapy on top of
this I could let me just say I
completely agree I completely disagree
with you because I'm not saying that
working out doesn't make you injury
prone but not working out makes you more
injury prone definitely then you would
have been because listen my back is in
better shape than it's ever been
hasn't caused me trouble and I firmly
believe it is because I have been the
most consistent with my fitness regimen
well I think that some of those injuries
like I know you've got a bad shoulder
I've got a bad shoulder I got the bad
knee now hopefully that's getting better
but I have to believe that it's not as
bad as if I was just in atrophy all the
time I started going to the gym years
ago because my right shoulder was
hurting and I I went to physical therapy
for a while and it made it better and
then I wanted to maintain but then my
left shoulder started hurting I said you
know I need to get back felt left out
some physical therapy to just to just
get this thing hanging right again or
something I don't know what and you
you know we both in a physical therapy I
prefer I've been in the two types of
physical therapy there's the one where
you're in a large room with a lot of
other people yeah and then there's the
one where I have a physical therapist
that I go to from time to time who she
just has an office and it's just her and
you're in an office and that's it and
that second scenario has proven much
more effective for me personally you
know you've experimented with both as
well but now you're going to the white
the open area again it's an open area
but it's one it's one on one physical
therapy and there's not
sometimes there's one other person in
there usually because I went to one
where they rotated on me yeah I did that
too that's that's no good you feel like
you feel like like cattle yeah yeah so
focus anyway I go in there and I'll just
use the first name Jane is that real
did I learn my lesson to not should I
call her Petey Patti this is not this is
not well who knows I don't think my
story's incriminated then I start
telling them and they probably are but I
love Jane she's she's a great person I
give her five stars on my review okay if
you were to leave one but you know when
you give it when your therapy is in link
Neal I guess you get in a weird
territory so I'll say that it's on me
not on her but here's what happened I go
in there I'm you know I'm I'm hyper
mobile and my shoulders I'm not doing my
exercises correctly at the gym I'm not
you know I'm not setting my my shoulders
back and engaging my traps whenever I'm
like doing exercises and my shoulders
are getting hyper extended but then her
immediate is doesn't want to walked in
what why is that confusing are you
making a confusing finish shoulders or
hyper-extended if you like let's just
say I did a bent over row like I'm been
over facing the ground and then I'm
gonna I'm gonna pull some weights up to
my size I'm gonna you know you know too
much shoulder and not enough back yeah
yeah yeah you got to set your shoulders
roll your shoulders back and down to
engage your your lats in order to then
protect your shoulders so that they
don't hyperextend out okay but then when
I go in there she's immediately
assessing my posture and everything I
walk out of there the first time with
like special flip-flops she gave you
special falafel
well she sold me special flip-flops that
how can a thort flop be special your
your foot Nestle's around the arch in
such a way as to drive up your heel to
be in the right place so that you're not
putting your you know if you watch
people walking you see people walking
they put they put weight on the on the
right side of the heel on the left side
they're not they're not centering their
weight and I'm sure you've heard this if
you're not walking correctly if your
feet aren't interacting with the terrain
correctly it has a ripple effect through
your whole body
anybody's your therapy will tell you
that everything is connected in your
body so I go in there for my shoulder
flop though what my feet the flip-flops
do they flop okay you got a problem with
flopping no I just thought that me I
don't I don't understand mechanically
how they work and I thought that maybe
like if they when my feet Laura if
you're walking wrong they trained me to
when my heel strikes to distribute the
weight centered on the heel and not to
the right I haven't seen you wearing
these especially my right foot I wear
him around the house
I'd like you to wear in a physical
therapy I'd like you to wear the
flip-flops in I have them in my bag I
wear him aware I'm home I fashionable
it's not really warm enough but no
they're just they're not on they're just
black okay I'd like to get into my story
I just you're you're raising a lot of
questions as you go I don't gotta say
the main thing about my show I mean
she's working on my posture and holding
my shoulders back and in my my head back
so I'm not hunched over you know so I
I'm filling my lungs with air and I'm
puffing my chest out and I'm being proud
to be Who I am
she says things like that to me and then
she lays me down on this log of a
fitness log I call it it's just a long
styrofoam cylinder
and I lay on that on my back and then I
splay my arms out and I lay there for 15
minutes doing snow angels this is this
is my task and I've supposed to do
snow angels yeah I'm looking I'm looking
good and it's basically to open up bring
my shoulders back they flop if you want
to flop my shoulders flop down on either
side of the fitness log and my arms go
out so my chest opens up okay and it
stretches my pecs and it's everything's
kind of closing down I need to just open
it back up and after doing this a few
days second I'm we're going there I'm
like I've got a hitch in my giddyup when
I laid down on this log and I start
doing the snow angel when I get right my
arms right here at like 2:00 o'clock
2:00 and 10 o'clock in much I feel this
pain in my chest like right around here
on one side and on the right side but
then it goes all the way back to my
shoulder blades she says well that
sounds like your rib and I'm like well I
do have this rib that kind of sticks out
right here you want to put mama
you might be able to see it don't touch
it huh I got it I'm gonna touch it
gently gently right there
you feel that and it's it's more on this
side yeah on the right I mean I would
say that's a mild I remember my mom
telling me that I had a fused rib I
didn't know what that meant and she said
maybe that's it
but then she started feeling of it and
it's like right here to the right of my
sternum in the middle of my chest
above my nipple towards the middle it
just feels like the the ribs poking out
and she and so I'm laying there and she
starts just doing what you did she
immediately starts feeling of it and
rubbing it and I just started I'm I
started squirming I would have started
laughing when they touch my chest like
they're doing a massage and then they
turned me over and they started working
the top of the shoulders and they
anytime the little little singers like
get down into the top of the pecs I'm
like well let me tell you I started
ladder I started laughing and I did
embarrass myself and it was like
you know it is so nice I wasn't I was
not I wasn't actually it was
uncomfortable laughter it's the same
type of laughter that I exude when
people start talking about blood flow do
you know that freaks me out yeah and I
was like like a grunting laughter kind
of like squirming getting away from her
and she's like pushing on my River she
was running to your lab and before she
could respond I was like I'm sorry for
laughing it just makes me really
uncomfortable I actually feel queasy
when you touch it and then she said you
touch it hmm and I was like I don't like
touching that spot
I don't like tasting that I never touch
it because I feel queasy at Pawnee spot
and she took some ointment this is LA
she took some CBD ointment she took my
hand out she put aunt Matan and then she
said just rub it and I'm like I put my
hand under my shirt why is this
understand like rubbing actually I can't
think of a part of my body that it would
be weird for me to rub I'm trying yeah
not having someone else rubbed if it's
me rubbing my body the whole point of
being taste my kryptonite the tick the
ticklishness comes from the unexpected
nature not being able to anticipate
what's gonna happen next but when you
you can't you tickle yourself we talked
about this on the show I'm not tickling
myself making yourself outta my rib
yeah because I feel like it's not in
place and like I'm touching it I don't I
just feels gross to me because it sticks
out man it's nasty lots of things that
stick out though like do all of them I
start touching it and I try to be
obedient and I'm like I'm rubbing this
spot and I'm like she can tell I'm
really uncomfortable and she starts
giving me this speech she says that rib
is is not mobile it's and it's you get
the pain all the way to the front of the
back because it doesn't like to move
like all the other ribs something's
happened to you in the past and I told
her I broke my pelvis she was like we
might have done it then when you when
you busted your ass and broke your
pelvis and got a concussion in college
and I said well whenever it
I still don't like touching it and she's
like you need to invite that rib to the
party
he doesn't have to eat anything but it
does have to show up she's saying all
this hawk this is the analogy this is
she said that many layers of the analogy
she goes into that mean layers about
whether or not the rib has to eat yeah
while I'm rubbing my own chest she this
woman's a genius she she is trying to
distract you she got you thinking about
how weird her analogy was and here next
thing you know you're rubbing her
rubbing that ribbon and having a it's a
party I can rub it now and she said I
mean it's still a little uncomfortable
as I'm trying to do it but she's like
you know what I understand that it makes
you queasy but this is part of your body
and your brain is telling you that
something's wrong with it and you need
to get comfortable with it being the way
it is before we can see some progress
but what are we how we gonna figure
doesn't have heat
do you want me needs to go to the party
push hard on it no she pushed hard on it
don't you push I think I can distract
you tell you a little bedtime story
about the rib going to the party and
then boom like it's scaring somebody
when they got hiccups I'll just press it
in real quick with a lot of force and
it'll it'll dislodge let me do it I'm
not I have a physical therapist her name
is Jane she tells me wonderful stories
about rib people she didn't get it - she
didn't fix it it takes time I gotta say
the intially it's this is it is like
mental therapy to do well it's kind of
reminisce a bit you have a rib that
needs to come to a party that's exactly
what I was about to say I bet you if I
went to this woman she would find a rib
that needed to go to a party as well
because I think not enough help nothing
against her I think this might be a
little bit like chiropractic medicine
which I understand that there's there's
benefit in chiropractic medicine but
there's also a lot of woowoo in
chiropractic medicine because no matter
who you are if you go to a chiropractor
you think they're gonna be like you're
perfectly in balance please go home no
they always say you're a little bit out
of alignment let me do this has anyone
ever been to a chiropractor who didn't
tell them that they were out of
alignment the only chiropractor I went
to is the one we made a commercial for
right the cracked chiropractor look up
that commercial if you're interested or
don't but yeah I kind of feel like this
is like one leg is a little bit longer
than the other kind of thing huh no she
was a
dressing my mental block do you think
you really got a rib that's not coming
to the party you think that's real yeah
Beth yeah yeah I mean it can hardly
stand up how do we get it to come with
the party probably touching and pushing
on it but I have to get a little more
comfortable with that how often you're
not touching and pushing on it I haven't
since the since the party analogy well
right now I'm touching it a little bit
okay I feel light on it I feel like
every night you need to you gotta push
hard cuz I think what's gonna happen
you're gonna be sitting there one day
you don't know you're gonna push and
it's gonna go and all your problems are
gonna go away and not just like
chiropractic not just your rib problem
all your problems are gonna go away if
you can get that ribbon in alignment
everything else in your body will like
dominoes you be like a transformer and
you'll be suddenly in great health she
says that I need to like put my chin
back I take issue with that too because
I've never thought of you as a person
with that posture I think I got much
worse posture than you you don't you're
always sitting upright yeah I mean here
link sits upright all the time doesn't
he he doesn't he he not hunched at all
man I think I'm Alexi Dennis no look at
me I'm always hunched because that's
what oh boy just because you have
problems doesn't mean I don't have
lesser problems that I'm dealing with
don't it's called envy Rhett you have
ringing me down I'm telling you that you
have good posture is not called envy I'm
telling you that if I were to line up
all of my friends and I and there was a
spectrum of good posture to bad posture
just eyeballing it in my brain right now
you'd be on the top in a good posture
when I watch now pointy ribs you'd also
be up there as well when I watched back
the vlog where we were playing disc golf
with tortillas I don't even know if that
video is out yet but when I watched the
the first shot of that of me like teeing
off and like throwing the frisbee
tortilla I was like man I'm not athletic
looking well that's it totally I mean I
think I'm goofy looking like I got a I
got a have a more athletic state but
that's not your posture and I think that
is you're taking Tech that's the key to
my shoulder getting better for
everything being tight and looking
cooler while doing things is the key to
get
don't tell me you don't believe that I
know that's your world well I will say
that from an athletic perspective that
the way that I've always tried like the
way that I tried to figure out how to
swing a golf club was watching people on
television who knew how to do it I was
like I don't really know exactly what's
happening but if I can make my swing
look more like Tiger Woods swing then
it'll probably result in something good
I found this to be true so if you can
look at frisbee golfers of the world and
be like I'd love to look like that I
don't even need to know exactly what's
happening you just need to look like
them you're probably being good shape
what's gonna start with a party where my
rib is gonna be there are my ribs
invited to the party sure they don't
have to eat but they do need to be there
okay I'm glad we cleared that up you
have a new shirt on I do this is B or
mythical best and 3d man it's gotta be
your mythical best written under it this
is like this is like advanced graphics
stuff you know to graphics in one this
is like something that me and you would
never come up with because we think to
to something inside the box when it
comes to graphics yeah we'd be the hold
on you forgiving others like underneath
the graphic you do you need to delete
that layer before we sell this shirt
that's what we'd say this isn't in other
words you're crapping on our merch no
I'm saying that that's what makes it
cool our merch has gotten way better
since me and you stopped being the ones
figuring out what was gonna go on this
year man we're so proud of it look at
him wearing it mythical calm check out
all the designs that have unexpected
twists turns shadows and redundancy and
coming soon to mythical calm a shirt
that has a built-in foam rib that you
can rub it's got a bump yeah yeah yeah
it's got a bump underneath it yeah rub
it to your heart's content and it says
rub here and there's in there's also it
comes with a packet of CBD oil rub rub
here to come to the party
dang it okay maybe we should be giving
more ideas from merch it's probably
expensive to produce you want to take a
look at some of these questions yeah
yeah yeah what are you gonna start let's
just start here at the top
these aren't questions these are things
that y'all are into Amy Smith Amy what
are you into
I love smelling things from entire
stores like tire shops or Home Depot to
Windex and commet to old books and old
photographs the smell of skunks gas and
even manure don't bother me I just love
to smell things I I think this is this
is great because to me this is this is a
form of being and like being in the
moment like you don't typically like I
mean the reason that the same stop and
smell the roses is what it is is because
you don't typically do that you don't
typically stop and focus on the scent of
something yeah I mean if if something is
pungent or it's a listening something
that is a like a warning it triggers a
warning in your nose like oh my gosh
somebody farted I got to get away but if
something smells good and saying oh that
smells good but I'm just gonna I'm gonna
suck it in like this is this is a
meditative mindfulness but the thing I
really relate to in this Amy is your
desire not just to smell good things but
just to smell things right yeah and I
think that one of the things that I
enjoy is you know strong flavors like I
think that anybody who likes black
licorice kind of understands it is it
that you actually think that it tastes
good or you're into that you talked
about it on the podcast or on GMM the
taste masochism the concept if you're a
masochist when it comes to taste and you
like strong flavors you like bitter you
like blue cheese and black licorice and
I think the reason I'm waiting is
simulating danger
but in the confines of safety it's like
eating a poison berry without the
consequences of the poison right and but
it's it's it's an experience and these
last three things that you that you
mentioned skunk's gas and manure are
like that might be my top three I mean
like I well it depends on them it
depends on the type of animal manure but
no but you know like I used to do it pig
manure no thank you Kalman knew but you
know what they used to do at NC State
where they'd bring in the fresh mulch
that had the manure mixed into it and
you can tell like oh there's this high
smell that's Cal [ __ ] and it's like ooh
they oh that there's fresh manure on
campus today and it's like some people
like what's that smell it stinks I'm
like I like it I like it I hate it and
that's why I love it yeah I don't know
what it is it's an evocative experience
a skunk
well like my dad used to say it was a
debt as a dead polecat when you smell a
skunk when you're just driving down the
road because apparently when a skunk
dies it releases its glands I don't know
yeah and also distinct scuzz it's dead
I definitely like and I don't know what
book I always like that what books were
books oh nice I do not smell my toenails
I do I do not smell the inner in inner
workings of my bellybutton usually that
would be difficult I'm not that flexible
with your finger you mean stick and then
pull and smell yeah sample and smell
sticking sticking ream and smell ring I
don't think my bellybutton smells bad
well I don't oh yes find out well let's
let you find out it's most totally fine
hide all smelly someday just minger well
listen you've got a sample size of one
day you need to do this every day do you
during your really meticulous lathering
routine that you do with the shower not
going
do you always lather everything
including the belly button yes I cannot
tell you the last time I wash my belly
button or my legs
that's gross man it's not gross they
smell fine smell my legs smell my
bellybutton I'm not gonna smell your leg
I'll put my legs or my belly button up
against anybody's and I bet you they're
just as fine well you need to ask
permission first before you do that I
wash all crevasses in my face and I feel
like I I'm doing good you wash your toes
weakly well then there's our that's a
bunch of crevices I know before crevice
I said the thing is is that he just like
I feel like you're drying your stuff out
man showers are not even a natural thing
Sarah what is the flame princess as her
moniker on Twitter says what is she into
bones but more specifically and this may
seem effed up human bones okay I want a
human skull more than words can express
there's something about facing your own
mortality by looking into the empty eye
sockets of a once living person and
seeing yourself oh this is is this
wicked or is this insightful well again
I know I'm a dark person but I very much
relate to this as well and I when we
went to Gaul we went to the Voodoo
Museum in New Orleans and I guess I'd
recommend it well it's not much of a
time commitment right here's like a 13
minute pretty much in and out and we
were really squeezing squeezing all the
juice out of that experience and there
are several human bones animal bones but
definitely human bones including some
human skulls and I gotta say there is
something very we were trying to figure
out if they were real and we did
conclude because they were just out
there I mean this is like a house that
you walk through well the human skulls
were in the one that eyes the one that
me and you and Britain were looking at
was in a glass box come yeah it was in a
glass box but that one was real it was
death it was real man yes like the
detailing on that thing I get this I
didn't I didn't process it much time how
would you get a human
skull we gotta kill somebody how'd you
do it legally
I wonder how does one acquire a human
skull yeah I'm sure you well legally
okay then can you can you look that up
yeah you want me to you want do you feel
like you need to go into incognito mode
or something go on the dark web yes you
can do it I know that you can get a
human skull if you're uh how does
medical file a human skull
like if you're a medic if you're a
teacher you can have a you can have a
skeleton in your classroom I know a lot
majority those are fake just molds but I
want you to be real because it's cooler
it is cool to know this was a person and
now they just hang out in this classroom
all the time so you're at your end of
this you're into what Sarah's into human
bones I get it
I I definitely I don't know if I
would've been into it until she said
that it's it helps her face her own
mortality by looking into the empty eye
sockets I think that kind of redeems it
Oh Jenna has found an interesting face
what did you find
Betsy yeah the Lauren room calm well how
much for a human skull and how did he
how you know it's real what do you mean
a normal human yeah
no an act I don't want to abnormal human
skull that's it
that's like a I want to extra big one
that's creepy on creepy old artifice
$2,000 well whose was that do they do
they have names Mrs Henry antique uncut
male skull 400 bucks so these are just
like skulls that are out there on the
market all right that's why that's what
I'm gonna get rap for Christmas I'm
gonna get one he'll forget I won't just
forget I said that
I'll get it for your birthday okay I'll
be happy let's move on to another
I'm creeped out Marcel van were Kovan
okay I'm into puppets I like building
performing and watching them okay I
think they're really cool because they
have this weird ability to connect with
people that I feel even sometimes people
can't
that's probably why people find them to
be creepy hmm puppets okay so yeah
there's a lot that could be said about
puppets when you when you read I'm into
puppets and you stop there for a second
I was like okay that's all I need to
hear it's not a good idea and then he
goes on I like building performing and
watching them okay this dude if we're
gonna rip this guy to shreds for his
love of puppets but now he's an actual
what what I can create or not gonna rip
anybody to shreds
he's freaking Marcel is freaking
real-life Geppetto I hear he's crafting
puppets performing and watching other
people perform with them so we gotta we
gotta be careful well I my assessment of
puppet loving well because my reaction
is my assessment of being into puppets
is that we are in magic territory here
we did a whole episode about this you
mean magician territory yeah magician
territory yeah and that is is is being
in a puppet school thing about that for
is being a magician cool door crystal
[ __ ] hold on you're talking about like
Jim Henson you're talking about like
next level labyrinth [ __ ] and now we're
not we're not we're not talking about
that we're just talking to me I don't
know I haven't seen Marcel's puppets but
I'm just saying the decision to get into
puppets is like the decision to get into
magic and here's just like I said you
don't get into magic or get into puppets
because being into either one of those
things is cool in the very superficial
traditional cool what sense of what cool
is
you get into it because there's
something that you like to do
but you need to Nestle you need to
understand that because of the way
society works you will be perceived in a
certain way by certain people if you get
into these things and you just got to be
ready to embrace that I just wonder how
how many opportunities there are for
public puppet work these days I mean
there's it's it's it's it's just got to
be about the love of puppets because the
people that break through and puppet and
puppetry mm-hmm this very small
percentage of people we knew a guy do
you remember a few years ago we we knew
this guy he was like a friend of a
friend he had the big gauged ears and he
was a couple he was a puppet man and he
was like and he worked for Jim Henson
and he taught our kids like puppets at
or art or something at the homeschool
co-op that the kids were a part okay
okay that dude first of all he was the
coolest puppeteer
so maybe I'm taking everything back he
had large gauges you know like the kind
that you could hang a puppet on each
year okay if you wanted to and you could
stick a puppet finger maybe you can
stick a puppet hand depending on the
puppet through his ear oh yeah and I
feel like if you can stick a puppets arm
through your own ear then you're cool
whether you do puppets or not like if
Fred Rogers Daniel the tiger can jump
through your ear hole then you're cool
yeah okay and the thing about it is if
you've got large gauged ears which is
not something that I personally
recommend but it's not something that I
personally judge either thank you my ear
is it you I'm gonna take that rib that's
sticking out and we'll pull it out and
stick it right through your ear Paige if
you are the kind of person that has
gauged ears you should balance that with
being in the puppets and if you are in
the puppets you should get you should
balance that with being doing something
like getting crazy piercings now
claymation a pierced puppeteer that's a
whole thing right there I can go to that
website
I hear slang nation that's cool pierced
puppets calm is that a website can you
look that up
here's two puppets I mean you're back
into voodoo at that point aren't you you
tell you mean like yeah boo doo doll
Lara
bencroft at mixed underscore veggies
underscore is into brushing my teeth in
the shot not my teeth
Lara's into brushing her teeth in the
shower anything in Pierce puffs is calm
yeah I moved on because I wasn't hopeful
brush it you ever brush your teeth in
the shower I used to I used to I have
strong opinions about this now
but uh but you go first because you're
the shower man I'm the shower man well I
mean every second in the shower is just
water down the drain and unless you turn
it off while you lather Sojat do that
yeah so like doing more stuff in the
shower to like I don't know I don't like
wasting that amount of water even though
we're not in a drought here in Los
Angeles it's interesting because the
here's where I was gonna say as if
someone who doesn't turn off the water
to lather but also as I indicated my
lathering process is not nearly as
thorough as mr. Nields therefore it
doesn't take me but about 17 seconds so
that's not a lot of water yeah it
probably gets washed off before it's
actually caught the nasties I stepped
out of the stream to lather and then I
get back into the stream but that being
said I used to brush my teeth in the
shower in North Carolina you know you're
surrounded by water there it's like
there's ponds every four feet creeks
it's like you know you don't get a sense
that the water is in short supply when
you're in North Carolina right and let
me ever see in Jordan Lake full of water
and when it wasn't and so I would brush
my teeth in the shower but two things
have changed number one I've moved to
California where I I've been sort of you
can't a drought you can't avoid being
more conscious about the water supply
but also this is not on know if there
are sponsor on this episode but quip I'm
you
because I'm using the equipped
toothbrush and I'm brushing for two
minutes which is how long you should be
brushing yeah two minutes of brushing in
the shower for a man who's not gonna
turn the water supply off yeah
that's their response I just move it I'm
completely moved to a different part of
my day I don't like the idea of
different part of them keeping my
toothbrush in the shower I don't like
the idea of other people's showering and
yeah that's just my wife but yeah I
don't know my wife's stuff rebounding
off my often your wife off it yeah where
she's like and then get getting on my
toothbrush does your wife lather as much
as you do I'm sure she doesn't that
would be impossible does she have a
shower system I haven't asked her
because I don't want to have a fight
hold on
y'all never shower together well right
when we shower together it's not as much
about getting cleaned but has her ever
in fact it's quite big but has there
ever been a time when we're just like
both independently in the shower just
showering just washing no really there's
been a couple of times I mean I'm not
nice like she's got a shower and you've
got a shower less you're not there's not
any shower play less than a dozen times
during 19 years of marriage we have
showered at the same time because of
convenience not because of other desires
okay there's been out there there have
been those scenarios where you know
shower play but what I'm talking about
is showering at the same time because
you both need to get into the shower why
is that what you're talking about
because the other thing is the
interesting thing to talk about well
let's talk about sex in the shower hold
on but right everybody well okay well I
was was trying not to talk about that
it's dangerous gotta be careful about
your thoughts I'm not moving on I'm
gonna keep coming back to this well I'll
talk about it when you're done but the
fact that I I think that your routine
your shower routine is so regimented
that no one else could fit into it
anyway we get first of all your shower
has two independent Shou
heads your shower is built for two
people to take a shower at the same time
am i right well the current house I'm in
but other homes that I've lived in that
was not a case huh
and I still did it what would y'all do
this alternate who's under under water
yeah you might as well just wait until
sometimes you do like a Patrick Patrick
Swayze and ghosts kind of thing like she
might be lathering and you might come up
behind yeah but if they're laughs okay
so now you're talking about no no but
it's focused for function is I mean yeah
it's a little sensual but it doesn't
have to be essential or practical it can
be both in fact when it's both it's
beautiful where the sensual meets the
practical it sounds like a tagline for a
class that you would see at a yoga
studio that you could tear off in Los
Angeles yeah I just I mean our place
where sexual meets practice - way to
tight quarters to just be in the shower
together just you've got a big shower
I've been in it yeah and I was in there
- it's not tight yeah but I don't know
it just seems like that's a personal
space unless it's unless you're sorting
the mail if you're sorting the mail in
the shower together then go for it but
like I said you got to be calculated
about you got to have a good foot hold
your hand hold you got it you just can't
I don't play that game the height
difference is too extreme for that to be
safe yeah and yeah it's always been for
me it's always been I mean it's it's
always rewarding I'm not gonna say yeah
but it's it's almost like it's too
challenging it's like in the the level
of dangers and potential personal injury
involved with like slippage and stuff
it's just there's too much anxiety
associated with I mean you don't want to
you don't want to have that much
pressure you know that's not that's not
good for performance performance
I'm just not into making love in the
shower okay this is what this has become
but brushing your teeth you're also not
into which was the original I liked that
in principle but I gotta remember to
bring my toothbrush in and then put it
away because I like it in my drawer so
it's not out
I don't like leave them a toothbrush out
next next thing that someone is into
from bu I am Beth I like that
that's cool that's calm I'm really into
going to show homes that I know I'll
never buy Oh like an open house just
purely just out of nosey the sign the
house is for sale a lot of cars parked
around here oh they're all going into
this open house now you know that this
is my dad this is my dad's past time
growing up we just we'd find houses that
you would drive around neighborhoods
just to drive around neighborhoods and
look at houses but and to go into houses
that work that were open houses okay
okay
in fact when they came out here a couple
years ago we went into like a really
nice neighborhood somewhere and
somewhere in town where there's like
multi-million dollar homes like up in
the hills and you just go on a Sunday
afternoon drive around and you get to
walk into these awesome houses that
those levels of houses still have open
home policy things they let just people
walk in off the street yeah I didn't
know I mean maybe not like I'm not
talking about like a 20 million dollar
home I'm talking about like a four
million dollar home okay you know which
in the Hollywood Hills or something like
that it's like I mean it's you you you
there's some interesting stuff I've done
it a couple of times so you tell me how
you've dealt with this because my use
the bathroom or not yeah one time it did
my thing is you go in there and there's
a real estate agent who kind of greets
you at the door and there's like there
they're giving out handouts with all the
information on the house to potential
buyers I know I'm not a potential buyer
and the few times that I've done this
but I found myself acting like a
potential buyer
as opposed to just saying you know I'm
just here to look around I think they
can look in your eyes they've done this
long enough that they're good at it and
they're selling the houses that are
worth walking through to know in a split
instance whether you're there as a
potential buyer or just to look around
because like B Y and Beth you're just
into it but I found myself just
instinctively lying oh yeah so um what
are the comps you know it's like go into
the kitchen there's another agent the
kitchen age these nice houses they got
they got double teaming with agents and
they're baking bread just to make the
house smell like it yeah yeah that guys
they got tricks up their sleeve you know
they sell a candle well they sell
candles that smell like baked bread but
they sell this thing that looks like a
loaf of bread that has an oil in it and
you put it in the oven when you're
showing a home and it makes your whole
home smell like baked bread but it's
you're doing that to bake bread yes
Jenny people turn the light on for the
oven you can see the bread it looks like
bread and you what how do you even know
about this because I was in a home one
time where they had it and Jesse was
like talking to somebody who was take an
open house yeah Wow
and I don't know if this is like really
hit it big yet Jenna could you look that
up she don't need to look at it I know
Jenna don't look that no because I know
I don't waste your fingers please please
look it up
fake baked bread oven smell home I don't
sir you like giving clues and password
what that's what I do I don't I do you
telling me you search actual questions
into Google I just put all the keywords
Google will assemble the answer furry
would have been plenty I don't know I
think I had to give it a home bread oil
would have been enough no that wouldn't
know that that we just give you fake
bread oil yeah but where do we where do
you buy one what is there a website fake
bread dot-com
we've come up this is hats this isn't a
proper good business ideas when you go
into a house do you tell him don't I'm
just looking around
Amazon what do you do you start lying
like I do you're like I don't I don't
well bred oil fresh bread so that's a
little different thing I talk about you
put in the oven but you know it's
ceramic bread that you drizzle oil on
yeah so I have an initial conversation
that makes it seem like they don't need
to waste their time if they're like
you're looking so you guys you guys
interested in buying if they ask a
question let be likely you know yeah
eventually so you do lie well no that's
not that's true
I am eventually gonna buy a house in the
hills somewhere no but you're lying
you're not looking to that house to buy
it you know me though I could go up but
when you say oh I could go up for a
Sunday afternoon just for kicks and next
thing you know I'm like with a lawyer
and buying the thing just because I'm so
impulsive but but no I I'm just I'm just
saying I'll because I want them to well
I sell them I don't want them to I want
a perfect balance I don't want them to
look at me like I wish he wasn't in here
walking around he's just wasting my time
and I also don't want them to interact
with me and try to follow me around the
house I'm just in there I prefer them to
not be there I'm just there to explore
so you say something that keeps them
from giving you dirty looks but also is
like I don't think he's serious I'm not
going to follow him around I'm not gonna
ask him questions that's the balance
that you want but they know they know
you they know they know the deal you
should but I do get this it is fun to
look at homes especially it's actually a
fun afternoon when you're lying to like
an it real estate agent that's fine you
know that's it's actually a good I
suggest this as a creative date a
creative date and this could sometimes
this think might move things a little
forward too fast if you're not actually
serious but you're dating somebody I
would say if you've dated somebody for
more than two months
than one year because after one year
this would no it's not any fun anymore
to do this okay pretend that you're a
married couple looking for a home two
months of dating you're gonna present
freaking pretend you're married listen
you know me I think I think like I'm in
a movie man I don't I I'm not gonna do
the lot play do the long play the slow
play thing it's like I'm like yeah it's
like it's actually a way to like I'll do
anything because you're married I I'm
talking about
the proverbial me that's not married
that and one time wasn't married this is
the kind of thing that I would have done
if genesee single ret I'm saying that
this is a good idea because it's kind of
like a role play to feel like it what it
would be like to be a couple and then
you would go into the shower and sort
the mail like no you can't use the
shower but I have urinated at an open
house but I've never taken a dump
yeah you better hope they have bread
oils in the bathroom you gonna have to
tell what he's been baking bread any of
you know what I mean
somebody's been baking some pumpernickel
in why you why you baking some
pumpernickel because it's hot is dark
brown and you have to pump it baking
some pumpernickel is like a Dookie man
because it's dark it's dark that was a
good joke and most people got it good
well I think we should let's go to the
next page all right yeah we just skipped
some ones because it it wasn't good
enough wasn't good but you're into
sucked so bad that we just skipped it
we're not even gonna tell you about Amy
replied to our prompt and said I really
love eating burnt toast I purposely
burned my toast so it'll be nice and
crunchy
it just has better flavor to be honest
she's built a flavor with au which means
that she's probably from the UK or you
know somewhere over on that side of the
she's a pond or a camara doesn't know
how to spell flavor
do you like burnt toast do you think I
like burnt toast
do you wish I like burnt toast because
you know I don't I I would
be willing to bet many many dollars that
you don't like burnt toast because you
don't you don't you differentiate
between the darkness of biscuits you
don't want a light basically every time
we go to Bojangles anything the biscuits
it's like you will hear the you listen
man you will hear this race can you give
me a lot as often it was so particular
that he has a biscuit preference can I
have a yeah I don't mean the type of
biscuit I mean the lightness of a
biscuit like the opposite of
pumpernickel biscuit right so yeah I
don't know what a Bojangles that often I
mean they're not out here so when I go
back home and I'm gonna maximize my beau
jingle experience I want it to be what I
want it to be I wanted to that's not my
impression my impression isn't that you
I don't know - you're trying to maximize
is that you would not enjoy the biscuit
if it was a dark my favorite yes you're
a racist against biscuit see my
45-minute burger is Shake Shack burger
and time before last I went there and I
was eating a burger and I was like
something's missing this is amazing but
it could be more perfect it's missing
onions if you order just like the Shake
Shack burger
there's no onions you got to give this
the smoke stack that has peppers they're
awesome peppers they are good but it's
like I like the just the classic taste
as well with onions and I had to make a
mental note next time I go in there I'm
gonna add two onions
yes like this is a monster caramelized
okay they said we don't have that but we
got something else like that it is
onions like yeah that's what I mean give
it to me did you stop midway through the
burger and get him I thought about that
time before last but then I just made a
mental note and never make that mistake
again and I did the same thing with
light biscuits years ago and I've never
looked back I don't like burnt toast
because it's burnt burnt is an egg is a
pejorative term hmm but if you like that
that's cool for you
Jack's bread let me okay let me give you
my perspective lon I'm gonna use I'm
going to use a
hand of brownies to make an analogy okay
so we're not talking toast we're talking
brownies fine and again I think that
this is my philosophy about most things
in life using but fine so you got a pan
of brownies and you've got people who
like the middle brownie and you got
people who like edge brownies yeah you
got people who like corner brownies
right yeah and then the way that I look
at the brownie pan isn't to like well
I'm a middle brownie man I'm a corner
brownie man I'm an edge brownie man
honestly the way I interact with with
the pan of brownies is what kind of
brownie man am i right now and sometimes
it'll be like you just look to me like
you were totally crazy we're saying
something that's a good point
but you looked at me like you were crazy
I just think it makes life more
interesting to not come to the
conclusion of what kind of brownie man
you are and just be like I'm gonna go
for the middle and enjoy the gooeyness
and then I'm gonna go for the corner and
I'm gonna get that crispy and I'm gonna
enjoy it and so listen some of us are
Optimus Prime and some of us have and
I'm just saying I lose or feel like
approaching toast in that way makes it
so that it's like sometimes it's
especially when you're not in control
because you're not I mean you're not in
control of most of your meals I mean
you're definitely not in control of most
your meals right cuz you don't cook so
therefore you you think I could cook
toast I'm just saying that if you open
yourself up to the world of both like
biscuits and dark mess kids then you can
you might appreciate the darkness and
the lightness and create a biscuit
balance in your life so all that to say
I like soft things not crunchy things I
like sometimes I'm in a burnt toast
everything's not burnt thing I get it
and I you know what burnt popcorn that
can be good too but it probably causes
cancer here's a weird one like I like I
like I don't like burnt chicken on the
grill but I like a nice charred piece of
chicken
that tastes good to me but what if the
meat gets dry that's not good okay 22
okay Amanda Marie you're up you say that
she says I collect caution tape from
construction sites that she passes
because I even have two pieces from
crime scenes with officer permission and
then she tweeted again after she like
thought about what we were probably
gonna say and she's like I guess I
should explain it I collect it because
it reminds me of all the places I've
seen in the world well you only go to
construction sites and crime scenes all
around the world other they are all
around the world I even have some in
other languages it's a unique way to
document my life yeah it is unique I'll
give you that Amanda Marie caution tape
from construction sites and then two
pieces of crime to pieces from crime
scene first of all officer so the
officer permission really only applies
I'm trying to aim see I'm trying to play
Sherlock Holmes here yeah she's going on
construction sites and taking down the
stuff that then people mindlessly walk
into construction sites in the pits and
in all a plethora of problems well
listen I mean this is a this is
endangering people this is let me just
make a couple of observations about
Amanda Murray okay
so Amanda Murray our Twitter name man
Murray comma bleak Creek her Twitter
name is lost mythicality and then in her
actual profile picture she's got a
picture with us so we know that Amanda
Murray is a good person so we know that
I gotta be yeah no no I'm gonna no I'm
not talk about just being nice to her
I'm just saying that I am using what I
know about her to deduce she's got great
taste in us that she is not taking away
tape from like around holes and stuff
like that I think this is probably like
oh I can tell that this part of the
construction site is no longer that
important like you know they finished
here but they no one's taking this down
yet I'm gonna take a little bit of this
tape and add to my large collection of
crime scene tape
or she only goes to construction sites
that have officers president and asks
them for permission I just don't know
how construction site Tate is different
from place to place enough to then be
able to remember where you were
well yes language would help if you
approach this like cotton then you would
ask the question one of the ways to
figure out if whether or not your
actions are morally upright is to ask if
everyone were to do what I'm doing what
would the net effect in the world be
it'd be a lot less construction tape and
I believe that if everyone did this
there would be a lot more construction
accidents because eventually you're
going to get to the good tape yeah
because everybody else is gonna take it
so I would have to say that I would
limit my activity to the crime scenes
with officer permission yeah so then
you're just creepy but you're not really
luring people into an in Juris
environment but I will say that second
one the construction tape is kind of
like hmmm okay I don't know about that
one
real-life crime scene okay they're easy
but that's the kind of thing that I
could get into crime scene do not cross
but you can take a little bit if you
want it yeah and sometimes I think you
can talk to an officer who's got the I
mean somebody has the role of crime
scene tape I mean it's coming from
somewhere right yeah yeah yeah so I
don't want to take you know I don't want
to take that but do you have the role
can I have a couple of squares what is
this conversation like I mean you're
walking up to the crime scene
there's officers there there they're
going about their officer business
excuse me officer it's like he's
immediately assuming it's like what what
happened here you know officers got to
put up with that crap although what
happened here what's going on you know
it's like no no no I don't want to know
what happened I just want some of you
can I have some of the tape is that what
so yeah I collect the tape from places
all around the world and you know it
helps me remember where I was when I
committed crime it is exactly the kind
of thing a serial killer I do in a movie
right I always visit the crime scenes
and ask for the tape I have a little
jovial exchange with the officer and you
know what those suckers do they give me
pieces of tea right we've made we've
we've accused Amanda of quite quite a
big but she's but she knows us but we
know she's a good person so you have a
person any of that stuff what do you
want you on a secret lady spider
oh this was this is from the similar to
the other one I'll put this on there
because I thought you'd be into it
I'm super obsessed with abandoned houses
and buildings I keep a list of ones near
me I want to visit and marathon content
of people exploring them on YouTube yes
take photos of them and look up their
histories of ownership I don't know why
I just think they're neat yeah I have
this is L what her name is L oh I
thought you were beginning to spell
something this is link2sd to be know
where the guy goes into the oh there's
one that where he goes yeah like old
malls and stuff we've talked about a
number of you this is a YouTube Chandra
well and I'll tell you a more accessible
thing because Li I'm with you on this
there's a reddit thread called abandoned
porn and it's not just like old
pornography that's been thrown in the
ditch we found both budget a lot of that
growth you get to the middle of the
magazine it's usually still intact right
right you gotta you can't tell way
through the soggy soggy cover you got to
get to the it's kind of like a pan of
brownies but the exact opposite yes
that's right soggy on the outside and
crisp in the middle oh yeah
Chris been taught oh gosh um there is a
reddit thread called a banna banna porn
and yeah it's just pictures that people
have taken of like
amazing structures I mean gosh I mean
all types of all tighter so much stuff
like this and both of us are really into
this it was like a fairy and like I
don't know down in the Bayou or
something that was abandoned years ago
and there was a flood that took this
ferry up the river and then when the
flood receded it just stayed there and
it was like I had a this a steam boat
with a big wheel and the big big wheel
in the back yeah
the paddle in the back thing paddle
steamer and somebody posted a photo of
it and then all these people started
commenting about where it was and how
they'd been to it and every year they
would go there to like spend the summer
because it was like near this like
camping area or something and every year
the the water level would come up and
move the ferry and then recede so every
year they would come back and it would
be in a different location and every
year it would be more and more
dilapidated and I actually think it's
gone now but I don't know how these
people discover all these things but
because you haven't really supposed to
get into a lot of them oh yeah he gave
me a book one you very fascinating like
a coffee table book that was he's a you
know beautiful pictures of the inside of
abandoned structures you know old hotels
and I absolutely love love looking at
these things but I haven't been in many
you know I think all the there's a
there's a few like old theaters well it
wasn't really abandoned but the the was
it is it the Pacific Theatre yeah is
this the one on Hollywood this Hollywood
Boulevard it's the one where one of the
Warner Brothers like died of a heart
attack in the lobby and it's where the
first Academy Awards was held yeah we
explored we had bored that got on the
roof and stuff because we were with
somebody who had access to the building
we have permission I went downstairs and
saw the giant air conditioning unit that
like super inefficient it's like a
dinosaur we have a huge belt like a like
a belt that was you know 20 feet across
and then in one of the one of the cool
things about touring was we got to play
in all these old theaters and we went
into the underbelly
of this one theater yeah that's right
and it was I don't know where this one
was but the entire floor of the theater
could be on these hydraulic jacks that
are like 20 yeah I mean like a hundred
years old could go up and down could
come up to meet the stage and then go
down and I don't even know why it worked
that way yeah I'm into this I'd like to
you know what I bet you there's a good I
bet you there's some good VR tours that
you can take of these old buildings
that's good you know if I knew that that
would be my rack I'm gonna give my you
know what I'll make this my wreck if
you're on reddit the thread is called
abandoned porn and like I'm looking at
it right now medical wing of Eastern
State Penitentiary
Westmoreland glass factory in western
Pennsylvania a castle in New York oh oh
this one in Bulgaria Bulls ILDA monument
cuz I'll cousin LOC Bulgaria it's an old
soviet monument now guarded and barred
from entry but it looks like a UFO
landed on the edge of a mountain with
this big obelisk with side it it looks
like something out of out of James Bond
and I should put that in a movie it's it
I mean and then you can read about it
because I don't know even if there's
only like ten comments one of those
people will know about it oh yeah it's
read it it's it's the main things
because when we were kids we would go
into hole you know we would go out into
the woods and there'd be cabins
well next in the woods that it would be
trees growing all around it there'd be
no access do you remember hell yeah the
we went to the cabin I know Ben and I
went there but then I think you and I
went there in the pasture that we used
to chase cows in and where the rocks are
mm-hmm if you were to walk like right
where you come into the pasture where we
did when we went to Buies Creek but you
walk all the way across straight instead
of going to the rock so you go past the
rocks and keep going straight and going
to those woods and keep walking
there was an old house that was just
sitting in the middle those woods it was
like a Hansel and Gretel type situation
because it was a house that had no path
no road no indication that there ever
was a road because it was so old that
the entire woods had grown up completely
around it any entries had grown up into
it and it was this old house and we
would go in there and a lot of I don't
remember that one but a lot of them that
you go in the kitchen there be stuff in
the cabinets and be old this one was way
beyond that like it bought wines and
stuff like but there was the one that
one of our friends brothers like
exploded with dynamite yeah
that had like a fully stocked kitchen
with a bunch of old clothes and stuff it
was a super creepy we had a lot of fun
there and that near my nanny's house
like I would drive her golf cart over to
this there was this abandoned house and
I went in there and there were
hand-drawn murals on the wall of
anatomically-correct women naked
anatomically-correct it might be pushing
it do you did I show it to you no I'm
gonna saying I remember the proportions
of the most of the time that portions of
the parts were no this is nice a
true-to-life
this is very accurate really it was like
a dot it was like a medical drawing yeah
it was it was I learned a lot and it's
funny because on Dolly Parton's America
like that podcast series she tells the
story of governing a love of sex and
abandoned church that had I don't know
what it is about abandoned homes that
make people want to draw like well
abandoned porn well yeah you don't want
to do in your own home especially if
you're gonna take a whole wall yeah
where else can you just draw a naked
person with their legs spread you can't
do that in your house you got to do it
in an abandoned house did I say leg
spreader did you remember I told you
that before because I didn't want I
didn't I didn't know if I wanted to say
that well the i i've got specific
memories of going into abandoned houses
and like going into the living room
like a fool yeah like a fresco this is
it like that's the I've never seen a
fresco get that fresh all right
I think I think we had a good time yeah
hopefully you learned you know you know
I think if there's any apologies owed
just go ahead and pre apologize to
Marcel
yeah Marcel tear for link saying that he
was about to rip him a new one but that
did end up happening because we talked
about how you know the the proper way to
approach puppets and then maybe you
might need I don't know if we need to
apologize to Amanda Marie we just need
to make sure that she understands her
Miranda rights true will speak at you
next week hashtag ear biscuits to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]